from day one it was clear that these
guys were creating their own imagery and
they're distributing to the press and
the press was eating it up
Michael Shaw is the publisher of bad
news notes a site dedicated to the
analysis of news images Shaw has been
keeping a close eye on how President
Obama's image is crafted for public
consumption in the beginning because
Obama was young his oratory is it could
be can be very powerful he there was
almost I think they were consciously
trying to develop some kind of analogy
or develop an analogy between him and
the Kennedys so if you look at some of
those early pictures from the White
House flickr set that they were
distributing you'd see a picture of him
running down the colonnade with bow the
dog and that picture if you put it
side-by-side which we did on the site of
the picture of Robert Kennedy running
down the beach in los angeles you don't
see much difference there there's
another image of Obama from behind where
there's a painting of JFK you make an
analogy and you're in your mind you know
that here's the young president is JFK
like there's another picture that was
very strategic I thought that had the
resolution desk which is the dust that
Kennedy used Bush used it also and in
the oval office early days and Obama was
there with Caroline Kennedy and she's
laughing kind of an off to the side and
then he's in behind the desk and he's
looking under and kind of joking around
but you know that the immediate
reference is and from a cognitive
standpoint what instantly pops in your
head is the way that that
psychologically connects you to to
Kennedy and makes almost a kind of
continuity between one figure and the
other when he's otherwise someone who's
extremely unknown is extremely powerful
there's a shot of him with a lightsaber
playing out and I think this is with
visitors for the White House with little
kids where it's like it reads Star Wars
or you have a picture of him running
around a pool with a super soaker and
it's like here's a black guy with a gun
you know running around but it's got
colors in it so it's got kind of
programming a lot of these associations
you it you would naturally have before
we knew he was running for president he
was a freshman senator from Illinois and
he sent out a Christmas card and if you
go back I think was the Chicago Reader
was saying wow it's really amazing that
you have this junior senator who's like
sending out a Christmas card to like
everybody in the entire city you know
the the visual savvy and that was
notable more notable if you look at the
card is who shot it it was taken by
Annie Leibovitz so I mean the fact that
they had this kind of visual savvy and
understanding and appreciation of what
photojournalism can do very high level
photojournalism and that images can
shape perception and also introduce
someone who again was so you know green
and unknown and and and other in a lot
of respects on oh it was was was really
really notable from from way before you
get to the White House
what's an interesting photo to look at
and I and I think and at the time I
didn't take that it at all as being
propagandistic was the first lady's on
official portrait it's taken in the Blue
Room of the White House and you see a
michelle obama with her hand on a table
and you wouldn't even necessarily think
that it was anything more than at white
house painting but when you look at the
photo what you realize is that painting
the bloom of thomas jefferson and how
brilliant and how eloquent really is it
that the first african-american
occupants the white house that her
official photo would be taken in
juxtaposition with a slave owner who
used to live there that showed a
understanding of the power of a visual
narrative and and even on a subliminal
level that is not that is not accidental
it's it's it's really brilliant but it
really did I think set the table for
them you know just having that kind of
consciousness about every situation
moment scene going forward
people know that that they're being spun
people do know that these are that
there's an advertising component and a
propaganda element as much as an
informational element I think people are
very savvy that way and I and I think
it'd be wrong to underestimate how much
people are looking at all this content
in a much more on a critical way or a
skeptical way
you